la chaleur et l'amour de sa mère.
Mais voici une photo de Torn avec sa famille aujourd'hui.
Sa mère a maintenant un travail sûr,
ses frères et sœurs s'en sortent bien au lycée
et elle est sur le point de terminer son diplôme d'infirmière à l'Université.
Pour la famille de Torn -
(Applaudissements)
pour la famille de Torn,
le cycle de la pauvreté a été rompu.
Le modèle de structures familales que nous avons développé à la CCT
a eu un tel succès,
qu'il est maintenant proposé par l'UNICEF au Cambodge
et le gouvernement cambodgien
en tant que solution nationale pour garder les enfants dans des familles.
Et un des meilleurs -
(Applaudissements)
Et un des meilleurs moyens pour vous d'aider à résoudre ce problème,
c'est en donnant la parole à ces 8 millions d'enfants
et en préconisant l'accueil en milieu familial.
Si on travaille ensemble à éveiller les consciences,
on peut s'assurer que le monde entier saura
qu'il faut mettre fin au placement inutile
d'enfants vulnérables en institution.
Comment est-ce qu'on y parvient ?
En redirigeant notre soutien et nos dons
aux orphelinats et aux institutions
vers des organisations qui sont engagées à maintenir les enfants dans des familles.
Je crois que nous pouvons rendre cela possible au cours de notre vie,
et ainsi on verra se developper des communautés bien-portantes,
s'assurant que les enfants vulnérables où qu'ils soient
aient ce dont tout enfant a besoin et mérite :
une famille.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)